Salam alaykoum are you guys doing we're
going live i'm here with dr. sabeel
we're going to be asking answering your
question what I'm at the LA hiva but God
the who it's an honor to be here to
share with you and all of us how to
share this wonderful faith of Islam with
humanity so me and brother Eddie would
be here for the next few minutes and you
are free to ask any questions that has
to do with the tools and techniques of
Dawa why we should do it why it is a
necessity so feel free to ask questions
but make it limited to the questions
about Dawa they're not just to you want
to get any questions you want to give
salaams to the people here at nine
aaliyah so so alaikum assalaam my dear
brothers my dear sisters walaikum
assalam warahmatullahi wabarakatuh who
may god's peace mercy and blessing be
upon each single one of you we have a
special episode coming up we dedicated
to talking about Muhammad Ali the
people's champion who was living the
life of this Dean this beautiful way of
life Islam he was sharing with it
sharing it can we get this um pamphlet
that actually he has his name sign down
did you guys know about that that he
would we talk about that and show that
what would he do he would he will
autograph hundreds of these what he
would do is uh you know even though he
was not able to talk but he could write
right so he used to eat each single day
he is to take a bunch of brochures like
this and he has to sign them and when he
used to go out on the street people used
to flock him for his autograph and what
he used to do he is to give these
brochures to them one by one and this
brochures used to have his autograph so
in that way not only they are getting
what they wanted they also getting the
message of Islam so some of the
brochures they were introducing Islam
Jesus is not God about Trinity about
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
prophethood in Islam purpose of life so
all of these brochures and hamdulillah
he is to pass those on to the people
especially to the non-muslims in this
way
in this excellent way our dear friend
Muhammad Ali used to share the message
of Islam these questions are going
really through here really fast let me
see if I can please forgive us if we
miss some because they're just we get a
lot of people tuning out hamdullah
brothers talking about is it let's see
cool what do we got here I'm they're
flying through a song Lee Cornell bless
you bless you too thank you thank you
guys for all the support thank you a
hundred Allah thank you so much no song
for me we got robbed Birdsall a clone
Mirage Salam alaykoum okay we missed
some questions we're waiting in the
meantime while the questions start
coming so we talked about Mohammed Ali
we talked about his wonderful effort
that he made even in his position that
he was in he was still out there you
know talking even before the parkin says
hit he was talking about the number of
hours in a day putting that together how
many hours in your whole life that you
actually spend to be on this world and
then paying the rent that is due to you
for being here is by serving humanity
and what better service to humanity and
then sharing the purpose of life
masha'Allah you know people speak about
Muhammad Ali a great boxer as a good
civil rights leader but of all and all
the things that he was he was a good
Shearer of Islam he used to convey the
message both in the ring and outside of
the ring both on live TV and also with
his family and children so these are
some of the very important ways you know
it's not just enough for us to praise a
person but if you love the person if you
like the person we have to follow the
way the legacy and the legacy of
Muhammad Ali the wonderful brother may
Allah give the muff era to him is to
share the message here we go I got a
question here now okay i see we how we
can use as we can scroll it down and
says how does one give dower to close
friends so how does someone share with
close friends without offending them or
coming across as judgemental etc good
question okay that's a very good
question suppose many times it's a
challenge for us to give dava to a close
friend because we will be thinking
fearing that we may lose the friendship
but it's very important that when we
realized that Dawa is important it's a
necessity because Allah subhanAllah
dimensions in the quran surah 16 aya
number 125 or the OLS abelia Rebecca
Bill hickmott eva moore is at El Hassan
atiba Jael homebuilder t he adds an
invite all to the way of Allah with
wisdom and fair preaching converse with
them in ways which are best at most
gracious so these friends sometimes who
we are hesitant to convey the message
they may hold us responsible on the day
of judgment that you know we used to
speak about politics and about economy
about the NBA the basketball but they
may question us on the day of judgment
why didn't you convey the message of
Islam to us so sometimes it may not be
easy to directly convey the message so
sometimes we have to slip in in the
conversations for example when you are
playing playing sports you could mention
that one of the reasons you are playing
sports because of the importance that
Islam gifts to spose if you are in the
cafeteria eating together you could
mention that you are restricting
yourself from eating from the hamburger
or from the steaks because of such and
such a reason so you could start with
any topic you could bring in a touch of
Islam and then you could lead them
towards tawheed saying that this are the
these are the guidance says that our
Creator has given to us you know just
like when we are in schools and colleges
we have to listen to our professor of a
teacher so we could pass so in this way
we have to listen to our great professor
the great teacher is a la sabana dolla
so a trick to convey the message is to
slip in sometimes the message of Islam
in the daily conversations important for
us to carry brochures like this I mean
you may not be able to see this says is
Jesus really God so there are many such
brochures we could send out so by giving
them a brochure this is a month of
Ramadan gives them some gifts it could
have candies in there it could have some
things that they could use along with
them along with that insert in there may
be a one minute card about Ramadan so
this could be some ways that you could
convey the message
if we don't David hold us responsible on
the day of judgment may Allah make it
easy for you and me it's a challenge but
inshallah once we make the way a la
sabana thought as going to open the
doors for us inshallah we got another
question coming how can we give Dawa
when all the negative things going on
about Muslims and people are people are
scared of Muslims you had this situation
now and obviously Islam condemns and now
obviously people are scared even too
because all of the negative publicity
but that's one thing we can see from
Muhammad Ali's like that he wasn't
scared he was a man of virtue of
principle and even and times of
adversity he would still get out there
and he was only mimicking the best of
humanity Jesus peace be upon him he gave
the Dawa Moses gave the Dawa and it
wasn't all sugar and roses it was tough
times that they were going through but
they still were out there sharing the
purpose making it known what the Creator
wanted from us so what would you say on
that that question Mel la sabana Tala
make it easy for a single one of us in
these tough times in this challenging
times very important for us we should
not we should not we should we shouldn't
stop doing dava but we should do da with
hikmah the way a la sabana that i
mentioned to us it's very important when
we look at ok so a day after the other
end of shooting on sunday the team of
dice we went out in chicago there is a
big festival going on we heard of a
dhaba table we were afraid that what
people may come what they may say what
they may do but alhamdulillah better
Eddie we had perfect response we have
positive response from the people coming
and asking us the questions and getting
the clarification from us that this is
what some Muslims are doing what do you
say what does Islam says so it's
important for us that we should convey
the message despite the challenges but
use hikmah second very important dava by
action that means be a face of goodness
in the society that's what a las bonnet
Allah wants
to do amra bill Maru fauna he an admin
car that means going and volunteering in
the soup kitchens in the public library
raising food drives letting clothing
drives relief efforts whenever we see
any calamities disasters giving blood
for the blood dried so when people see
Muslims positively proactively
peacefully and gauging and enhancing the
society inshallah that could also be a
very good way of doing Dawa in these
challenging times forgive us if we don't
get to everybody's quoting we've got a
lot of people to annum getting a little
bit familiar with how this live stream
works much love from you guys thank you
i love you love you guys too thank you
thank you very much i'm here with dr.
sebile and from game piece and we are
talking about sharing because if you
care you share and let's see if we can
find another question here well done job
I'm to LA if giving down what other
person doesn't looking at some questions
see if we the thing that happened in
Orlando how is Islam related to this mr.
Trump is blaming it on Islam your view
on this jazakallah Haider Islam doesn't
have anything to do with it Islam does
not incite violence Islam insights peace
Islam came to give justice Islam came to
fight violence so it's very important
for us to distance ourselves from the
acts of a few misguided Muslims and
bring them close to what the teachings
of Islam is and we should reason with
our friends our colleagues our
classmates that they are good and bad
apples in the followers of any ideology
may that be Islam Christianity Judaism
it is a many ideology so there's a long
list of laundry list of the acts that
Christians have done but we as Muslims
we don't hold back Christianity
responsible for it in the same way we
should say to the Christians non-muslims
that he has their good and bad apples
they could be doing the hideous acts for
whatever reason whatever cause but
important what does is
says and we should bring them back to
the teachings of Islam reciting chapter
5 verse number 32 taking one innocent
life is like taking the life of all
humanity saving one life is like saving
all humanity and there are many examples
of such a prophet muhammad peace be upon
him so very important for us to give
them also the facts because sometimes
Fox News and CNN ends all of these
Islamophobes they make it appear as if
all the acts of violence that done by
Muslims even in Europe by the way
despite the Belgium attack despite the
French attack obviously we should first
and foremost condemned them and condemn
all violence secondly we should give
them the facts by showing two thousand
eleven twelve thirteen fourteen fifteen
and even now today even in even in
Europe less than two percent of the acts
of violence unfortunately they're done
by the Muslims even one act is too many
but if you look at the statistics by the
euro pole it says less than 2% by the
Muslims even in the USA FBI has mentions
from 1985 to 2005 and even now less than
six percent they are done in the name of
Islam we could give them the statistics
about the Washington Post last year 2015
355 acts of violence mass shootings were
done in the USA only three were
attributed to the Muslims you know even
one is too many by the way but we have
to show them majority here Muslims maybe
one or two acts and even then we condemn
those so when we show them the facts and
figures and then lead them towards what
Islam says it came to distribute to
spread justice and peace and equality
and morality and then show the verses of
the Quran an example from prophet
muhammad peace be upon him if we have a
brochure give it to them if you have a
website that Dean show calm gain peace
calm mention this to them right and also
be a part of the society engage and
enhance the society when they see the
face of Islam the face of Muslims
positively proactively engaged and
enhancing the society that that showed
that sense fr gray
message than any worse that we could say
so these are some of the ways my dear
Muslims we can even in this challenging
times we could convey the truth using
hikmah inshallah I think that many of us
have a false perception that and you can
comment on this thinking okay if you
give Dawa you have to just come in
straight forward and you know maybe just
get into the six articles of faith the
five pillars right away off the bed now
I mean they are there's obvious dawat
through your behavior your example but
you gave a great example also that at
one point dr. sabeel saw his neighbor
was going to get a ticket it was snow on
the ground he had his car parked the
wrong way so what did he do I mean that
good character of yours is going to go
ahead and motivate you to want to go and
be courageous enough also you might
disturb him a little bit but it's for a
good cause so you don't get a ticket
right so along with being of noble
character being someone who is
hospitable good mannered you also have
to you know share give the information
somehow and we started off in this
week's show talking about how Muhammad
Ali was doing that and how you can do
that by making people aware of the
reality of death the reality that we
didn't come from nothing that design
indicates a designer that there is a
purpose everything around us has a
purpose so there's different ways to
bring up to how people think because
people are trapped in the TV box all day
football sports but getting people what
would you say to really reflect about
why we are here what is our purpose to
think beyond just money sports and
fulfilling our desires and then
hopefully you know it will get the
wheels turning slowly that they'll start
to one investigated to look into you
know what's out there and if they're
sincere and if they ask the creator for
guidance they'll definitely find it in
this way of life yeah you know so that
example the example of mine that brother
Eddie did that my neighbor was sleeping
his car was about to get a ticket I woke
up the neighbors saying that the police
is coming and if you don't move the car
because there was no
on the road I woke him up and hamdullah
you know he moved the car but on there's
only the part a of the story the part b
of the story was he invited me to his
basement and he wanted to know more
about Islam also the Sunday the day
after the Orlando attacks we were out
there with the Dawa boot it lady came up
there and she said this is what she said
I saw a dream last night that my friend
in the dream told me to go and learn
about Islam and then she said she saw
the sign about the discover Islam boot
that we had she came there she learned
about Islam she took a copy of the quran
translation and we hope and pray that my
love on earth Allah guides her and all
of humanity so we should not get
discouraged what we see out there we
should not get frustrated we should not
get depressed but that energy that we
have the emotions sometimes the anger
that we have we should take it out and
channel the anger and spreading the
piece by good actions and good words so
we got a lot of questions we cover them
pretty much some of them in what we've
just been saying doc sabeel let's go
into a couple more before we conclude I
thank you guys for tuning in with us
live and you can watch this weeks
episode every Friday we have a new show
in sha Allah and this week we're going
to be talking about Muhammad Ali and his
life let's get into another question
before we conclude so one question
people may ask is uh here's one come in
an atheist during a debate asked me if
there is a Kurt if there is a creation
there should be a creator then who
created a low what is the reply for him
okay fine so this is a typical question
that people ask okay find you guys
believe in God then who created god so
it's very important that first and
foremost we have to make him acknowledge
that there is a creator so once he
acknowledges and then we have a whole
program that we did
using biology biochemistry physics
cosmology and obviously the Quran in
science argument that that there is a
creator now the question is who created
the Creator it's very important that if
there is a creator but definition he is
the creator that means he's the first
and he's the last there is no one who
was before him he is all he always is
existing that means he does not need any
creator about him or any parents and
grandparents about him from the
mathematical point of view is also very
important there is no such thing as a
infinite transgression of events in time
the concept of infinity we should tell
to the Atheist is a mathematical concept
it's not a real life practical concept
so God is the very first cause there is
no one before God if they were then you
have to find out who created that person
in that person and that entity in that
entity and you could go forever but
infinity is only a mathematical concept
you have to stop somewhere and wherever
you stop that is the creator and
everything else is the creation so
hopefully we could elaborate more on
this some other time insha Allah but
that could be a response that we give it
to them that if they understand there is
a higher power that means that higher
power is beyond space and time and
matter and these are some of the
attributes of Allah subhanAllah he gave
us the guidance the Quran and through
messengers because of the love of
humanity if they also follow means the
humanity follows this the message of God
they would have peace and purpose and
justice and equality in this life and
they would have eternal paradise in the
hereafter I said it's a responsibility
on every Muslim and a Muslim is simply
one who submits their will to the
Creator to heaven or earth as how we say
Jesus was a Muslim Moses was a Muslim
Abraham was a Muslim the last and final
messenger they all call to the same way
of life into our obligation to live it
to be the best ambassadors to it and to
share it
and we're doing also a campaign this
month to go ahead and try to have
everybody you know we talked about the
millions that are being spent certain 59
million plus as of last year by the way
this year they may increase that so
Islamophobes to fight Islam and to
spread hate they are spending 159
million plus you know if they could come
together for their common cause of
spreading hate why can't be Muslims
share our resources and support the
wonderful cost like the Dean show each
single day each single ve single month
consistently for the many years right
since one 2006 we're going on 11 years
now hamdullah over 500 episodes may
Allah accept haha alright eNOS it's all
of these needs energy it needs efforts
it needs finances you know when he has
to call the scholars from so many places
around the world who has to pay for the
plane ticket the lodging and all the
wonderful ways we have to accommodate
them so for all of these things this
blessed month of Ramadan where Prophet
Muhammad's of the dollar salam said that
the donation in this month are the best
donations because that multiplied so
many times so donate support due to our
carry on the message of Islam and may
Allah subhanAllah gives us the ease the
motivation the inspiration that all of
us coming together as the United Muslim
Ummah become peace ambassadors of Islam
to all of humanity like to thank all of
you guys may be dr. Seville can come and
check out the questions and answer them
later if they're in the comments if you
have some time but thank you so much for
tuning in remember I'm gonna have dr.
sebile inshallah this week friday every
friday we got a new episode of honda LA
and this week is no exception and we
talk about Muhammad Ali along with some
of the current things that are happening
and will have the description of how you
can contribute and donate we'll see you
next time until then if you haven't
already subscribed to the Dean show to
get the shows every week contribute
support keep us in your duas assalam
alaikum peace be with you